[Musique]
bonsoir
quand c'est une tête north je ne suis
pas content patron nicolas et
pimprenelle ont été si méchant avec moi
hier soir que je ne descends pas les
voir oh rien qu'une petite minute north
pour les mettre au lit non et non je le
renvoie à ma place ce petit chat qui
leur remettra de ma part une très grande
lettre mais moi je ne descends pas
bonsoir petit chat
essaye de les rendre charge et eau
tiens un panier cette techno dance qui
l'envoie lots mais pas trop mal
c'est mignon un petit chat
[Musique]
non jargon pas preneur il apporte une
lettre ce chaton il a mais je sais pas
les icônes à ce mot là c'est sûr où
étais tu le nourris on pourrait lui
téléphoner oui les téléphones
toi
[Musique]
000 alors aux longs
murs à la parole c'est un très bon ami
nicolas c'est toi qui nous écrit oui moi
merci bon le petit chat sait pas lire
nous
et bien les enfants je vous écris pour
vous dire que si vous l'êtes pas savent
je ne viendrai plus vous voir et que je
me mettrais très en colère
oh mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit
dans le téléphone
attendent au dos à l'eau non
c'est le petit chat il t'offre un dbz
chat mais nous on voit deux autres sages
pour te faire plaisir c'est vrai c'est
promis de nous et on va tout de suite en
ligne et en cas d'actes écopé ici et
merci pour le petit chat
data
oui je suis très content je viendrai
demain
ono
n'est pas venue petit chat d'armes
autres et ça
nicolas connu dix heures tu dors bien
[Musique]
et voilà un nounours heureux aux patrons
ceux qui sont mignons quand ils ne font
pas de caprices et bien ne vous fatiguez
pas bonne nuit et enfin embrasser bien
fort aux parents
soyez toujours bien sage avec nounours
est faite que pour
[Musique]
oh